ora tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi posso
finalmente dirlo ragazzi non ci posso
ancora credere abbiamo finalmente
ragazzo uno speciale un milione di
iscritti che è incredibile
grazie veramente ma veramente pazzesco
voleva ringraziare veramente tutti
quanti per gli auguri perché mi avete
tempestato di messaggi sia twitter che
facebook e youtube sono esplosi con
messaggi di auguri per i milioni di
iscritti ragazzi veramente non so come
ringraziarla premente lo sa anche mia
nonna che ha raggiunto il milione di
dischi grazie ancora comunque ci saranno
tre speciali per i milioni di iscritti
ovviamente non soltanto questo però
questo volevo farlo perché me lo stavate
chiedendo ormai da mesi sarebbe una
sorta di per chi ancora non lo
conoscesse una chat webcam live room
tutti voi se con quelli che riesco a
prendere probabilmente essendo un
milione e siete un po tanti però ci
prova e detto queste ragazze dire che
possiamo cominciare come al solito
scriviamo nude nutella negli interessi
perché se siamo proprio razzisti verso
chi no a chi non piace la nutella
diciamo ok consenti dove perfetto regalo
zabel salve le trasmetta nati ma che
ecco buongiorno è neanch'io ma aspetta
come fanno venir tease ancora testa che
io già sto male così porca vacca
so che nel vostro mondo state appesa al
contrario quindi è un po di febbre non
sulla p4 minuto così altrimenti ne il
computer agi il computer sino a ragazzi
non ci diamo la giriamo il computer
direttamente
oddio è mai scambiato per un cane quello
che è riconosciuto lui perché mi
somiglia di la verità è successo a
regalare come state tutto a posto
calma e che chiusa ma ti può dialogare
proprio la mente uccisa è bellissimo
[Musica]
ammirate cotanta bellezza non ha fatto
aspetta
ma facciamo un apporto lo facevano ha
fatto un senso in seguito siamo scelti
aspetta magari ci possiamo fare una foto
insieme
vai vai vai fa foto questa sponda di
grande abbraccio ne legga una frazione
multiplo grandi ragazzate fantastico
situazioni per il migliore anzi è un
grande grazie milano
buon proseguimento a prossima
ciao cosa scusa se non ti piace alimento
lui mi metto vi mettono tranquilla si
può stai calma ma rilassati amica mi con
come come ti chiami piace piacere fa vj
john zhao giorgia la georgia calmiamo il
cese mettendo ansia proprio già facendo
la foto proprio così stai facendo
dimmelo prima che ne so io almeno inizia
fare cose decenti ascolta non è che per
caso visto fuori già da qualche parte
sto cercando la mezz'ora tipo mi dai una
mano un di make a benny de sio accostate
ai file ha fatto che l'ha fatto per la
mischia alla prossima all abbraccio
se siete grandi settori vi voglio bene
[Musica]
ragazzi non avete il microfono vivendo
vai apre perfetto ma cosa prenderlo da
prendere e ti va un po di schweppes sono
io e lui aspetta aspetta è arrivato nel
salento sla tesi bambino fatto il video
le foto testa
[Musica]
a 20 anni ha detto beh oddio che perché
sai non cambi in casa amica mi ha avuto
bene amico e sbattuto la faccia
siete siete fantastici fare parecchio
aver truccato e così programma incarti
così sì sì sì sì ma io lo faccio già
prima che la mattina mi sveglio tirava
testata e sono così stato un piacere
anche per me ragazzi si trova in
residenti voi non vi uccido klm anche
voi perché adesso cercate farmi da te mi
date una mano
facciamo così no no col collaboriamo che
lavoriamo che funziona
oddio ma chi è quel figoli a destra in
foto avete una foto con me come fate a
verona foto con me
[Musica]
dice il papa
ma sono un fake ti pare ha continuato a
girare potendo tutti battaglino ho detto
continuate a gare iridate e la cosa mi
sento di 22 volte facciamo lezione dio
che insieme
ripetete dopo di avere troppo di me
provate brave perfetto amo fare queste
cose
city sta ascoltando la madonna
grazie di certo qui la regala non c'è
problema io io non c'è nessuno ad
abbracciare abbraccio lungo bovi
potrebbe anche darsi tabelle un saluto a
te la bambina è anche a bob marley
falliti andrebbe un po di nutella solo
gli in tema certo fra anche bob però
perché sono un c'è poi me l'ha fatto
fare con michael jackson la foto ok
perfetto ragazze è il momento più bello
della mia vita
spetta a michael un attimo che facciamo
fatto il giro perfetto la per la
maglietta ti stimo per la maglietta ti
stimo ok il trio e allora se voi me ne
vado non c'è problema ciao alla prossima
dopo cercato con tempi e ri andrò a
dormire perché come devo dire trovarsi
ricordano la buona notte a napoli j
niente auguri per tutto alla prossima
favi già in tv come stai
ma per chi ha segnato cosa foto fatta
voto tranquilli ma dimmi per impegnare 6
si può dire ho detto sì 61 cedolino no
sono ferito ha detto che sono stati che
ancora di inventarsi allora no non sono
un fake merda cioè senza iscritto
semplice meta penn serchio a sto punto
che stiamo suo amico avversari lo so lo
so c'è un casino di gente normale treno
mila persone vabbè adesso anche obama
probabilmente non lo so la veloce il
carico era quasi un anno che stai
ma lasciamo si calassero musicale
assurdo vai vai vai sua la suola la
[Musica]
fino alle una e mezza che si sposerà lo
so lo so che c'è tanta gente amico mio
però te lo devo dire sei un grande
abbraccio
vai abbracciami abbracciati come si deve
perfetto ecco anche kart ma tutti fatti
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj v6 a lui è un attimo un
attimo si chiama così c'è un attimo 86
tranquillo nato a quando è è impazzito
[Musica]
ragazzo troppo buono non è che posso
toccare il tuo amico di dietro non so
che faccia a faccia con che ciao anche a
te non è che per caso hai visto obama lo
chiedo perché sto cercando sono da
mezz'ora così tutto bene che succede hai
visto un fantasma che il successo non
vai saluto da mista soddisfazione grande
io non sono
madonna però sono famiglie e proprio
spero vada bene lo stesso hai visto e
allora facciamo così che così stampare
eccolo qui perfetta adesso direi che sia
un pari che di questa mattina ti sei
direi che adesso siamo di nuovo pari che
diciamo fantacci io farei uno screen di
questo momento perché è bellissimo
grazie a zio
questo posto sta ricercando cielo letto
dal cartello che mi stanno cercando
forza non lo so vi seguo sul serio sui
capelli di ceglia scusa mi dicono cimino
per prendere condiviso la giornata non
lo so
allora vieni più che un abbraccio ci sta
mai amico mio perfetto
forse
[Musica]
sono felice quando ho iniziato questa
sessione dio mi amigo avevo praticamente
19 anni adesso ne ho cinque leggermente
scocciato malata a posto tante rimane
era una cosa da fare questa l'accordo
ragazzi re che posso concludere qui
perché sono stato tipo traore suo amico
una roba pazzesca
guarda io ci metto una vita ti può
montare video d amico quindi uscirà
l'anno prossimo comunque ragazzi voleva
veramente ancora ringraziarvi per il
milione perché è stata veramente una
cosa pazzesca è veramente trovare le
parole giuste per ringraziarvi e è
difficilissimo quindi io comunque ci
sarò sempre per voi perché vedo vedo
vedo le reazioni vedo tutto quanto e non
posso veramente che essere contentissimo
di tutto quello che sta succedendo
quindi ragazzi grazie di tutto
abbiamo comunque già detto ragazzi
adesso vado in vacanza riprende a fare
video dalle 19 quindi stomia circa una
settimana in il boss spaventatevi se non
escono vinto perché non sono morto sono
semplicemente in vacanza poi torno
tranquilli e chiedere ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto come il nostro
documento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non divido tratta nella
descrizione essendo se ne avresti
discrete mitch picchiavano prossimo
video è la ragazza